Let's look at the answer to
our temporal locality quiz.
In this code, the question was which
of these memory locations have temporal
locality, and the choices were J,
sum, and the elements of arr.
Temporal locality says that once
we access a memory location,
were likely to access it again.
For the variable J, this is true,
we are using it here, here,
here in every iteration of the loop.
So the first time we access it,
if we conclude that it will be
accessed again soon, we will be right.
Actually, once we begin accessing
its going to be accessed a lot.
It's going to be accessed to initialize
it, to check if it's less then a 1000,
to access the RA, to increment it,
to check, to access, to increment many,
many times.
So this variable definitely
does have temporal locality.
The variable sum, same thing.
It is being initialized and
then in every duration of this loop,
it is going to be red, so
that we can add something to it,
and then written back to memory.
So this definitely also
has temporal locality.
Once we access it, we can conclude
that it will be accessed soon again.
For each element of the array arr,
however, and note that the array has
many, many memory locations,
we do not have temporal locality.
Element arr of 0,
once it's accessed in the loop, that's
the only time we access in this loop.
We will access out of one,
out of two etc., but for
each element it's accessed only once.
So, if we conclude that when it's
accessed it's going to be accessed again
soon, we would not be correct.
So, this choice should not be selected.
This variable does not have
temporal locality in this code.